I know right! Whose balls did I have to
fondle to get my very own movie?
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie Ryan
Reynolds just posted a big X-Men X-Force teaser
for Deadpool 3 so I'll explain what it means in
classic fashion he's trying to make as many jokes
as possible giving as many spoilers about the
movie away as possible tongue-in-cheek clowning
on X-Men and X-Force but it's actually going to
be part of the plot of the movie if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos we're also doing a Guardians of
the Galaxy 3 Imax ticket giveaway since the
movie's coming out in a couple weeks all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber and post
all your Deadpool and Wolverine predictions in
the comments cannot wait to see them ruin the
Multiverse in the best possible way it wouldn't
be a Deadpool movie if he didn't totally wind up
destroying everything in sight while clowning on
everybody in all the Marvel movies as much
as possible that's one of the beauties of
the Deadpool character is that Marvel will use him
to clown on themselves on the other Marvel movies
thank you Kevin feige Love You Kevin feige thank
you MCU if you thought him making fun of the X-Men
movies was a lot just wait till you hear him make
fun of the Marvel phase 4 movies is going to be
fun the actual X-Men and X-Force teaser he just
released on his Twitter is meant to be part of
Deadpool 3 he posted X-Force will never die then
quickly edited that to say x will never die hoping
that people wouldn't see it but it was a bit
tongue-in-cheek like oh yeah we could definitely
see what you wrote before this and it's just
meant to be a joke on a couple different things
it's him saying they're going to revisit both the
X-Men movies and the X-Force team from Deadpool
during the events of Deadpool 3. it is part of the
larger storyline where Deadpool is jumping around
the timeline creating Nexus events which gets
him on the TVA list after which Mobius
Owen Wilson's character who's going to be in the
movie comes after him with TVA agents to prune
him which we learned in the Loki series really
just sends them to the void Planet at the end of
time waiting to be eaten or consumed by eliaith
the planet was basically like a glorified trash
dump for the Multiverse like they weren't actually
killing things they were just sending it to this
void Planet waiting for for a light to consume it
because Elias basically consumes entire timelines
entire universes so they were sending everything
that he who remains version of Kang didn't like
or was creating Nexus events or leading to evil
versions of himself to this void planet to be
eaten by eliaith because they're revisiting
the X-Men movies and X-Force I don't know if
that means he's gonna kill the X-Force team again
because he killed most of the team during Deadpool
2 that was part of the whole joke of the team like
let's hype it up big time and kill him right off
the X-Force X-Men post is also a joke on the whole
naming convention from Deadpool 2 because during
the movie The Joke behind the creation of the team
was that Deadpool said X-Men was too misogynistic
a title for all the women on the team so he
changed the masculine sounding X-Men name to
something more gender neutral thus the team became
X-Force X will never die as a former X-Man trainee
thank you Bedlam I was always appalled by the
blatant sexism in the group's name X-Men men
the point is our group will be Forward Thinking
gender neutral from now on will be known as
X-Force isn't that a little derivative and then
quickly thereafter the entire team almost died
with a few exceptions like the post in general
is also a reference to Colossus and Domino coming
back in the new movie the surviving members
of the team no words on Josh Brolin's cable
coming back Kevin feige did make it sound like
he was up for him coming back like oh yeah I'd
be totally fine I think that's just because his
performances Thanos was motion capture he looked
totally different so he feels like a completely
different character when he's cable directors
that do that in Marvel movies all the time like
Michelle yo and Gemma Chan are both characters
that just came back after playing other characters
but this is also meant to be just a general joke
about Kevin feige and his snipers coming for him
after posting about X-Force like that's why he
changed the post to X to be more vague don't give
away spoilers or Kevin feige will come for you
we have no idea how that happened but I promise
you I'm looking into it they're in the middle
of working on the movie right now Hugh Jackman's
been posting his Wolverine training videos pretty
regularly he's calling it his becoming Wolverine
again workouts because he always has to get in
such insane shape to play Wolverine even if he
doesn't have to be shirtless for most of the
movie the way that Ryan Reynolds talked about his
version of Wolverine in the movie is that it was
a complete departure from all the other versions
of Wolverine that he's played before they will be
messing with the timeline but that's how they're
avoiding retconning the events of the Logan movie
like they're just avoiding that because it
happens later in the timeline and they're
jumping around in multiple different timelines
so they can avoid the Logan timeline like for
example how is Wolverine alive yeah after Logan
Logan uh takes place in 2029 totally separate
thing Logan died in Logan not touching that that's
how we get a version of Hugh Jackman wearing the
classic Wolverine yellow costume from the comics
or possibly multiple different comic book costumes
the way Marvel's been pitching it is meant to
be this big turning point during Marvel phase
six it's one of the early Marvel Phase 6 movies
now just based on the way they've shuffled the
schedule and when they talk about Tipping Point
they're talking mostly about the incursions and
the time Runs Out storyline from The Avengers
comics where you basically lead into Secret Wars
Avengers 5 is going to be king Dynasty and that's
mostly the dynasty of Kings as we found out in the
Ant-Man the WASP post-credits scene and that's
going to be a little bit different in that it's
mostly going to be the dynasty of Kings as this
King the Conqueror called them during the Ant-Man
and the WASP quantumania post-credits scene
like the Council of Kings he just called them
the dynasty of Kings going after the Avengers and
any of the other characters from The Multiverse
that we've seen like Clea for example that have
been able to breach the Multiverse been able to
cross between universes so when they started
teasing the idea of incursions during Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness The Tipping Point
that they're talking about is Deadpool base
basically doing a version of Deadpool kills the
Marvel Universe and just going off the rails with
incursions destroying a bunch of timelines but
that's why I've been making jokes about Deadpool
kills the fox Marvel Universe because Kevin feige
recasting a lot of the X-Men the Fantastic Four
characters inside the MCU so what better way to
give the fox Marvel movies a big send-off and
honor them and make fun of them a lot canonizing
them through the Multiverse just like they
did with Toby Maguire Spider-Man movies Andrew
Garfield's Amazing Spider-Man movies in Spider-Man
no way home and then proceed to do a version of
Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe but just have
him destroy or mess with the fox Marvel Universe
I've done a couple videos about how Deadpool 3
is going to be a huge Crossover with the Loki
series because the TVA Mobius and Miss minutes
are going to be big characters in the movie
here's how they are explaining Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine in the movie as well as pulling off a
bunch of the fox Marvel movie cameos with older
actors coming back to play their characters again
like OG Fantastic Four actors more Classic X-Men
actors come coming back the movie is meant to be
a direct continuation of the events of Deadpool
2 where Deadpool ended the movie taking Cable's
time travel device visiting several points in his
timeline as well as other timelines changing the
past like killing a variant from his own timeline
the original weird looking version of Deadpool
and Wolverine Origins he killed a version of
himself in another timeline before he made the
Green Lantern movie he messed with Baby Hitler
and they're just going to say that he continued
messing with timelines in the fox Marvel Universe
until eventually he tries to save a younger
Wolverine from dying earlier in his timeline
like before the events of the Logan movie but one
day your old pal Wade is going to ask you to get
back in the saddle again and when he does say yes
and that's how Hugh Jackman's Wolverine becomes
part of the plot when they first meet they fight
like Deadpool versus Wolverine or Wolverine versus
Deadpool however you think about it Hugh Jackman's
been revealing the plot just joking about how his
Wolverine can't stand Deadpool as you would expect
they talked about this in their big teaser video
last year but part of the joke of the characters
like The Comedy of a Deadpool movie with Wolverine
is that both of them have crazy healing factors
so they would just be able to lay into each other
chopping every bit of their bodies off and healing
it almost instantly so the fight would just go on
forever eventually the TVA detects all the changes
that Deadpool is making to the timelines he's
causing so much Havoc destroying the timelines
the TVA Mobius Miss minutes come after him and
that's how they get involved in the plot that's
how they explain this is a Marvel movie because
those are core Marvel characters now in the MCU
I don't know if Tom hiddleston's Loki will also
have a cameo in the movie because they're supposed
to have so many different cameos in the movie but
while Deadpool is jumping around in his timelines
that's how they feature a lot of the cameos from
the old Fox Marvel movies like they're supposed
to have cameos from the original Fantastic Four
movies I don't know which characters are supposed
to come back right now there have been rumors
about Chris Evans coming back as his Johnny Storm
he said previously he would love to do that it's
only coming back as Captain America that he's
kind of reticent about they were gonna have
Fantastic Four cameos in Deadpool 2 but it was the
original version of the movie back when Tim Miller
was still directing it and it would have been the
Fantastic Four characters from the newer reboot
version and the funny thing is I just posted a
new Fantastic Four video for Adam Driver because
it sounds like he's going to be the Mr Fantastic
in the MCU version of the team because we just
got the Council of kings in the Ant-Man the WASP
Quantum Mania and they're going to be in Avengers
5 King Dynasty like they're called the dynasty of
Kings we also might wind up getting a version of
the Council of reads so they can actually do even
more with the classic Fantastic Four actors let me
know in the comments though if they're going
to be jumping around in a bunch of different
timelines doing Easter eggs for all the Classic
X-Men movies bringing back Patrick Stewart even
bringing back Ian McKellen's Magneto character
what other characters do you want to see come
back in Cameo scenes I'll do more videos for the
movie when they release more teasers they're going
to be filming really soon so we'll start getting
some more footage from the actual set everyone
click here for all my Deadpool and Wolverine
videos and click here for my new Adam Driver
Fantastic Four movie video thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe and maximum effort!